it's only right that we start off this
video with Disney's legendary character
who pretty much paved the way for all
the fairy tales to come Mickey Mouse I
only hope that we never lose sight of
one thing that was all started by us now
The Little Mermaid is pretty perfect as
is but seeing our Disney friends make an
appearance has made it all that more
awesome which to be honest I didn't even
think was possible check out this clip
of King Triton's entrance to the Little
Mermaid what are you guys able to spot
Mickey let's slow it down and try one
more time now we clearly see Mickey with
his best friends Donald and Goofy right
by his side if you got that one on your
own then good job because you are
definitely an Easter egg hunting pro but
I can totally bet that you did not
notice this other character in the scene
hi-ho Kermit the Frog here don't believe
me check it out guys this was definitely
a bold move on the side of Disney
animators since they didn't go on to get
the rights to The Muppet Show until the
year 2004 that is a whole 15 years later
it's a good thing that the Disney fans
did not have the technology we do today
or that could have been a sticky
situation for Disney if you are one of
the eager fans who stuck around after
the credits started to roll for Finding
Nemo you may have noticed our favorite
one-eyed monster Mike Wazowski swimming
across your screen and taking a look
right at the camera as you snorkeled by
this is a clear sign that our pals Nemo
and Mike both live in the same connected
world
retail is all this time it's just quite
a bit in common with a jungle adventure
which doesn't take place until 10 years
after it that was Beauty and the Beast
so um what's he gonna call it I'm gonna
call him Tarzan in 1999 the movie Tarzan
came out and it didn't take much for
fans to realize these hints that the
Beauty and the Beast and Tarzan or
somehow related like the lyrics say two
worlds one family this is probably a lot
more literal than people realized since
we have many reasons to believe that
Jane is Bell's great great great
granddaughter Jane certainly seems to
have the same style as Belle and don't
even get me started on their attraction
for big brave and beastly men if that
isn't enough to connect the two how
about the fact that we seed mrs. Potts
and chip make an appearance this could
definitely have been a tea set that
Belle and her family kept throughout the
generations this could definitely be a
great reminder for future generations
that being mean to old ladies who come
knocking on your door has its
consequences the theory that Pinocchio
and Princess and the Frog are connected
is tied together by something oh so
magical the brightest star in the night
sky now you might have heard of the star
not only in the two connected movies but
some other movies as well I'll give you
guys one hint it also starts with the
letter P this movie is none other than
Peter Pan the right and straight on till
morning so where exactly did we see this
star for starters and Pinocchio we see
Geppetto who is Pinocchio's father wish
with all his might on the brightest star
in the night sky in hopes that one day
Pinocchio might become a real boy lucky
for Geppetto the star turns into the
blue fairy who hears his wish and
eventually grants it and the princess of
nephrotic we see ray the ever so
romantic Firefly who ends up leading
Tiana and Naveen to mama
Odie we also catch him constantly
talking to the evening star ray of
course thinks that this star is a
Firefly just like himself so he falls in
love with it and even ends up giving it
in me Evangeline at the end of the movie
we see that Ray's wish to pass on and be
with Evangeline is finally granted not
only was this a beautiful moment but it
is also the second time
that we see the night star grant a wish
and finally we have Peter Pan where the
night star please perhaps the largest
rule
it helps Peter Pan Wendy and the rest of
the gang fly back to Neverland
now seeing his princess in the frog is
all about things not really appearing as
they truly are
would it be too far-fetched to think
that Rey was in fact speaking to his
love Evangeline who knows guys maybe in
some faraway part of the Disney Universe
Ray's actually a prince himself who gets
his own happily ever after Oh wouldn't
that be romantic
[Music]
both Moana and lilo from lilo and Stitch
are set in very similar tropical
settings Moana is from the polynesian
islands and lilo is from Hawaii many
Disney fans were quick to point out this
Easter egg of Moana sheltering a baby
turtle with the leaf and helping it get
into the water now we see this same
scene after the end credits in lilo and
Stitch now is this Easter egg enough to
connect the two storylines together
probably not but this might be check out
this photo of David nonny's friend from
lilo and stitch notice anything peculiar
the necklace he's wearing is pretty
identical to Maui's fishhook isn't it
but what exactly does that mean and how
did David get his hands on a demigods
magic staff the answer is a peanutbutter
eating tropical fish called Pudge who by
the way also controls the weather now
didn't Maui sing about being able to
lasso the Sun to stretch our days and
bring us fun and why would Lila want
Maui to keep the Sun around the reason
is actually very sad now as some of you
might remember the Lowe's pants were
said to have died in a car crash on a
rainy night now is it possible that
because Maui wasn't properly able to do
his job and protect the people of Hawaii
the other gods decided that he should be
turned into a fish until they decided
otherwise now it could explain a lot
David is definitely shown as a great
surfer as he wears his necklace with
everything else we've talked about today
this theory does not seem too
far-fetched thank you for watching guys
and that is the end of our video and
all I've got for you today now I want to
know of any other connections that you
guys have made so let me know in the
comment section below
I am always on the lookout for the next
big Disney scoop so be sure to get
creative now as always don't forget to
Like subscribe hit me up on Instagram
and I'll see you next time on the things
[Music]